which movie version of Batman is the
most powerful we'll treat their films
like their video evidence big a real
physicist study them to extract hard
numbers on their attributes then have
our Batman compete in three batches to
settle who has the best Batmobile back
gadgets and bat strikes this is power
levels we're restricting our competitors
to the Batman who kept the role for more
than one film
sorry cleaned ugh there's Michael
Keaton's Batman 89 Christian Bale's Dark
Knight and Ben Affleck spat flick for
our challenges they'll have to race
their Batmobile through Gotham grapple
gun their Joker's up a building and
deliver their most powerful strike to
send him flying off the side whoever
performs the best in each section gets a
point most points after all three is
crowned our most powerful let's do this
we start with our bats behind the wheel
the plan of course around Gotham will
extract data from the map of the city
from the novel no-man's land using the
scale at the bottom we can trace an
accurate 12 mile track with a jump
across the Gotham River at the end and
for the results we'll need to know how
fast each car can go
let's check the stats of each Batmobile
some of which we pulled from their
real-world engines while other stats we
outsourced to other bat enthusiasts on
the internet because give us a break now
we can compare their top speeds and
damke in but top speed isn't everything
as they race they'll have to accelerate
and decelerate as they hit the turns
cars turn thanks to friction the force
of the tires and Road exert on each
other the sharper the turn the more
friction they'll need to keep from
sliding out to see how sharp the turns
are we'll measure average u.s. roadways
and assume a road width of 12 feet with
a turn radius of 26 feet and we'll find
their max turning speed by figuring out
the max force of friction their cars
could apply on turns with that sharpness
a few assumptions here for simplicity
one that they're all using the same
tires two that their centre of gravity
is in the centre of the car and three
that they're all equally good drivers
[Music]
at a glance
Keeton's car looks like it would turn
about as well as his neck but he's got
an edge a car mounted grappling hook
this cable provides more force towards
the center of the circle formed by the
turn this in addition to the friction
from the tires allows him to maintain
the highest speed on straightaways and
through turns now let's see how far they
fly when they hit the jump at the end of
the course we can plug in their velocity
gravitational acceleration and a 45
degree launch angle into the equation
for a projectiles range and out pops
their distance keys and sails the
furthest with bat flick a decent length
behind and the Dark Knight's tumbler is
too slow to even make it over the river
[Music]
would they Lucius would they after one
challenge Batman 89 takes the first
point now they have to yank their
respective Joker's up a building via
grapple gun to find out whose gun could
do this the quickest we need to find the
mass and average velocity as someone
being grappled upwards by each Batman
with this data we'll be able to
calculate how powerful each gun is once
we know the power we'll just need the
mass of each Joker to see who wins
fun fact according to her physicist a
grappling gun that small is completely
unrealistic wait that's not fun still a
fact though movie God will start by
analyzing clips of people being grappled
straight up by marking objects we can
reasonably guess the size of like the
stories of this building we can see how
much distance they cover in a given time
and find their velocity then we'll need
the mass of the person being hoisted up
sometimes this means looking up the
actors masts and articles about their
training regimens but sometimes Batman
just straight up asks how much do you
weigh then we add a few pounds for good
measure
a real pistol room our final variable is
the mass of each Joker which we found
from interviews with Leger and Leto but
Nicholson was harder to track down we
decided to cross-reference his reported
height five-foot-ten
with his body mass index profile which
after a rigorous debate we settled that
overweight but not quite obese science
this gives Keaton a 205 pound Joker to
dance with in the pale moonlight with
all our data in hand we can run the
numbers and see that Letta will zoom up
the side in 1.8 seconds quicker than you
can say sir Martha ledger eyes is a
close second at 3.2 seconds at Nicholson
and dead last yep anytime now there he
is giving fat flicks a point for
challenge number two
but even the best bat can't hide in the
shadows all day at some point they got
to step out and kick some face to find
the force of each Batman strikes will
find clips where he gives a bad guy his
best shot then we'll use that video to
gather the data we need his victims mass
how long Batman's foot makes contact and
their change in velocity after being hit
first let's time each kick then measure
the velocity like we did for the
grappling section to get their change in
momentum with the bad guys momentum and
the kick contact time in hand we can
calculate the force of the kick itself
back foot is the clear winner here but
the force applied that's well over a
professional fighting athletes average
of about 5,000 Newtons
for reference it takes about 4,000
Newtons to break a bone and while our
physicist wouldn't confirm this Jared
Leto has hollow little bird bones so
look out if they ever meet on screen
again if we take a look at the
challenges all its back like wins the
most challenges overall with the
quickest grapple gun and strongest
strikes yay sorry Bale The Dark Knight
didn't rise today but in your defense
you spent the fewest years actually
batmanning in your universe and when you
look at how the other two turned out
probably a good idea to retire to Italy
or whatever so even though Bale is my
personal favorite that data doesn't care
about my feelings but don't lose hope
viewers let us know who you want to see
compete and you can see them face off
right here in the next episode of power
levels
[Music]